ihre wunderbare starke kluge frauen
liebe smarte herzenswärme hübsche jung
gebliebene männer liebe liebe nicht
männer erstmal vielen vielen dank im
bundesvorstand
ihr habt einen wunderbaren überhaupt den
idealen ort für diese geburtstagsfeier
gewählt nordrhein-westfalen denn die
ministerpräsidentin ist frau die
stellvertretende ministerpräsidentin ist
unsere frau die präsidentin im landtag
ist wie der name schon sagt frau die
chefin vom bund vom
landesverfassungsgericht ist frau und
wenn es ums geld geht die
landesrechnungshof chefin ist auch eine
frau also ohne uns undenkbar
gut gewählt ja liebe freundinnen und
freunde eher was für eine woche
und was für ein wahnsinn sie scheinen
sich gerade wieder verabredet zu haben
die breitbeinigen die flegelhaften die
testosteron gesteuerten die glauben die
macht unter sich aufteilen zu können
die glauben das aufbegehren der frauen
wieder zurückdrängen zu können und so
die alte geschlechter ordnung
wiederherzustellen
diese drums diese erdogan diese putins
diese arbeit diese gauland und diese
ganzen afg konzerten
sie mögen bei manchen ja die erwartungen
wecken es könnte alles wieder so werden
wie sie es sich aus der vergangenheit
zusammen fantasieren mit echten kerlen
die im fall von trump auch mal gerne
frauen angreifen und zum bloßen objekt
degradieren dürfen
ich sage euch geht es bestimmt nicht
anders dass eine solche haltung dass ein
solcher sexismus in dieser woche ins
vielleicht mächtigste amt auf diesem
planeten gewählt
werden konnte das macht mich wie euch
einfach fassungslos und deswegen
schicken wir unsere grüße zu vielen
vielen freundinnen und auch freunden in
die usa
die brauchen jetzt unsere solidarität
aber aber die erwartung wir würden nun
klein beigeben
wir werden uns jetzt entmutigen lassen
diese erwartung sorry
die können sie sofort und ganz schnell
vergessen denn wer das glaubt wer das
glaubt er weiß nicht wie unendlich viele
kämpfe wir frauen schon ausgefochten
haben und es sind wirklich unendlich
viele kämpfe und wie stark uns diese
kämpfe gemacht haben und wer das glaubt
der kennt uns ganz offensichtlich
schlecht uns grüne frauen und die werden
sich wundern die werden sich wundern
denn wir kämpfen ja nicht erst seit ein
paar jahren für gleichberechtigung und
wir wollen auch nicht nur wissen gleiche
rechte und wir wollen auch nicht die
hälfte der macht erst im himmel wer weiß
denn ob man da überhaupt hinkommt und im
ganzen tag hosianna singen weil sie auch
nicht ob das mein lebenstraum ist
sondern wir sagen wir wollen die plätze
und die macht im hier und jetzt und
jetzt bitte ich frauen kommt dass alle
frauen kommt auf die bühne
mehr
wenig